if you just spend the time to learn
whatever it is well
you're you're competing with people who
are having to do the exact same thing
and by reading the manual by spending
investing the time to
to try to get upfront on technology you
can be ahead of the curve
when i think of the professional
salesperson i think about a professional
communicator
someone who knows how to make contact
someone who knows how to control the
conversation
billionaires they have exceptional
people skills
now some of them are great communicators
want to be happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack
of belief in yourself you watch these
videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level of
genius at something so today let's live
your best believe
life and learn the seven skills with the
biggest potential to make
you rich enjoy
okay let's kick it off with skill number
one learn
tech skills with mark cuban most people
don't spend the time particularly in the
tech world just
to read you know you know the beauty of
tech is that
it's changing every minute of every day
and there's really
two class of people in the tech world
the person or people who invented it
and then there's everybody else and
other than the people who created the
technology
everybody else is in the same boat you
know if you just spend the time to learn
whatever it is well you're competing
with people who are having to do the
exact same thing
and by reading the manual by spending
investing the time to
to try to get upfront on technology you
can be ahead of the curve because most
people won't put in the effort
you've got to find the things that you
like because to me the key to success
is finding something you love to do and
then trying to be great at it
and you don't have to to know what that
is like i didn't i took one computer
class in college and i cheated at it
you know and and
and but when i started really getting
into it
i could spend 20 hours teaching myself
the program and writing then writing
programs and i
was like i had no idea i love this stuff
right
and and i would just sit there and days
would go by and
and it and i loved it right and then as
i got more into those businesses it was
like
this is great i'm having a blast doing
this now i'm going through and teaching
myself neural networks and
you know doing the same thing with
machine learning and gans and this and
that
because ai is going to have more of an
impact
than the internet did ai plus new types
of chipsets
plus 5g is going to change things far
more than we've ever seen
anything change and understanding where
and how to apply it
is going to be critical but just as
important knowing how to sep
segregate and separate the [ __ ]
right is as important because
every email you are about to send me is
going to say
i have this ai solution and we're using
algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if
i didn't do that work if i didn't sit
down and do the aws machine learning
tutorials if i didn't go on youtube and
take
you know the nyu introduction to neural
networks or whatever i'm not going to
know it i'm not going to be able to
apply it and i'm not going to be able to
be
first and that's fun that's fun knowing
i get to kick the ass to some 22 year
old nyu
graduate that's awesome i focus on
things that are
ai driven artificial intelligence driven
whether it's machine learning deep
learning
learning neural networks um medical
applications
but within ai ai is a buzzword that
everybody's using right now
you know every and and to that point
you know we as old guys we go back and
it's like 1995 we talk about the
internet
and i would say to people back in 1995
look if you don't understand the
internet you're not going to be able to
do business
and now that's just blocking the
tackling it seems obvious back then it
wasn't
right i could even take you further back
to my first company you know what we did
it was a company called micro solutions
and we did local area networks on wide
area networks
and i used to walk into companies and
and say you're going to have to hook
these pcs together at some point
that'll make you more productive more
effective you know give you a
competitive advantage and
people are like now i just carry this
floppy from this pc
to that pc yeah okay um
but today we're at the same type of
inflection point
with artificial intelligence you don't
have to be an expert
and be able to put together your own
neural network you know you don't have
to know what weights and biases are
but but you have to have more than just
a cursory understanding
just like you have to know the
difference between you know
different types of websites and you have
to understand e-commerce if you're in
e-commerce
you have to have a cursory understanding
of how apps work
you're going to have to have at least if
not more cursory understanding
of artificial intelligence because it
will change
everything we do and if the internet was
10x in terms of change to business
artificial intelligence will be 100x or
more
if you go to my house right next to my
bed there's a book
machine learning for dummies if you go
into my bathroom
there's deep neural networks for dummies
right if you go on there's something for
dummies
in every room of my house you know
[Music]
they can go two ways i know but i'm just
telling you
put the time i mean i i've taken you
know i can't even tell you how many
hours now i spend every week
if not daily working like i'll go on to
amazon aws
and go through their machine learning
tutorials don't think to yourself i'm
not technical enough or i'm not going to
get this or i don't get into this or
it's too much try it get as far as you
can because
it's like doing a basic website and a
little bit of html
just having done that you feel smarter
and you feel a little bit more confident
about this
you know i don't want to be an alarmist
but i'm trying to scale the hell out of
you because it's important
skill number two learn sales with grant
cardone
explain how you went from a salesman who
was in it and hated it
yeah to then you know you moved on and
became self-employed and then you were
speaking about sales and you're like a
sales expert so that's what
20 years in between or 10 years yeah no
there was uh there was maybe
uh 25 by the time i'm 26 i'm the top 1
of all sales people in the auto industry
i didn't really know what that meant
but but it was important to me that i
was
very good at what i was doing now now
now i was in i
i went from hating a job in car sales i
remember going out with this girl and
she said what are you doing i said i'm a
car salesman and she got that look on
her face like oh my god
that's worse than a man yeah you know i
mean and
and and i had this terrible thing i'm
like okay i'm going to get great at it
i started studying sales every day i
started recording interviews like
literally you'd come in to buy a car
from me and and i hired my mom my mom
was 70 years old at the time and i hired
my mom and i said you sit over there and
you take notes
really and watch her watch when i lose
her watch what happens and we're going
to
debrief at the end of the deal and i'm
going to see what's working and what's
not i'm recording myself
videoing myself i'm using every little
piece of technology 30 years ago i came
to find out
what am i doing right what am i doing
wrong and what i was doing i didn't know
it then but i was basically
codifying sales i was learning
what does it mean when i say i'm gonna
think about it when is that real when is
it not
what does it mean when it says the price
is too high when's that real when it's
not
and i started codifying and writing
taking notes keeping all this
information i didn't know this would
happen but
five years later i'm out on the road
knocking on doors
uh selling a a new way to sell things
let's talk about when you started
working for yourself
because you know most small businesses
fail in the first few years yeah one to
three years
yeah that most don't make it yeah i mean
there's a lot a lot of different numbers
out there about that like
50 of all businesses fail after about by
seven years the truth is they were
failing in the first
six months okay what do you think they
did wrong they don't know how to sell
anything
i mean you you go to harvard yale or mit
they're gonna if you do studies
oh the reason they were under
capitalized okay look this is completely
ridiculous what they're telling you
okay you don't you don't capitalize a
business
and then run out of money that's not how
you do a business right this is how wall
street does a business they rip people
off they basically go
most most companies developed by wall
street or in silicon valley are complete
ripoffs
of the investors you hear about the
netflix that made it
it might not still make it it's still a
negative cash flow business
because they don't know how to sell
their products fast enough in quantities
big enough and it prices
high enough to basically fund the future
so businesses fail for
one reason and one reason only because
you can't sell your products fast enough
in quantity is great enough and it price
is high enough
to sustain the business thus harvard
says oh they ran out of capital
yeah why because they didn't sell their
products
so if you can sell products fast enough
quantity is great enough google
google's a company you don't consider a
sales company google
sells products in quantities that are
giant
yeah yeah it profits margins that are
high enough
before you diversify go go bang on
another door
yeah you need to become the freaking
door
doorbanging
or the universe so i want to talk about
that right because can i use that word
here
you need to become like you need to go
yeah you need to go bang on the door
they tell you to get out of the
neighborhood and you go
figure out how to bang on it again and
not get arrested yeah
like if you can figure that gig out i
guarantee you you will be the most
successful person
your genetic code has ever generated
yeah
anyone in your family everybody i know
says man
learn how to cold call i i have the
career i have today because i'm
because i learned how to cult you need
to learn how to communicate with people
okay the the the the site here says the
powerpoint says
learn to become a professional
salesperson
when i know when i think of the
professional salesperson
i think about a professional
communicator someone
who knows how to make contact someone
who knows how to control a conversation
i don't think about a swindler
i don't think about a tricky dude i
don't think about a huckster
i don't think about a scam artist i
think about
dude this guy showed me something i
didn't know you know how many things
that i almost bought were the wrong
thing but a professional salesperson
with a full pipeline said no no
you don't want that one of the best
salespeople i know okay guy named robert
i'm not going to give his last name
because i don't have permission
i'm sure he wouldn't mind 25 billion
worth of real estate hey robert is this
a good deal
yeah you know but that's not the one i
would do i would buy this one over here
if i were you
okay see he's a professional he's a
communicator he'll tell me what i'm
doing wrong he'll tell me when i'm right
tell me when i'm wrong he'll
challenge me he's not playing games
trying to like
match tones i saw this video the other
day matching people's song did you see
it
okay get get right at the right moment
at the right moment lower your voice
and i don't want to do that i'm talking
about a professional salesperson that
doesn't have to rely on tricks because
their pipeline's so big there's seven
billion people on the planet that are
qualified and interested in buying your
product
you do not need to trick people and
that's why so many people think
commission
i don't want to be a salesperson equals
i don't want to be a huckster well you
don't have to be if you're a
professional
you guys don't like sales because you
ain't got any courage
that's why you want to be a you want to
be the vice president of something
that's why you guys want to call it
something else okay most of you in the
room don't even have sales on your card
you you sell real estate for re max okay
or keller and you don't even have sales
on
the card you're in network marketing you
refused
we don't do sales here
what do you do then okay what do you do
i mean i think the company's got a
financial statement
you ever read a financial statement
what's the first line on a financial
statement
huh what's that first line it's the
first line by the way
okay i've seen a bunch of income
statements in my life the first
the first ones are like two to maybe max
four inches long
big companies big giant companies okay i
got five companies they run to one
financial statement
and the top line the top line the sales
line you could call it
i think it's called also what revenue
could be called gross revenue
okay you know people are getting
confused now
okay they start getting away from this
word some some some
college guy came in and said we can't
call it sales man
we've got to call something like at
least two or three words
i mean i went to harvard it's not about
how much money you make folks
can you use money
can you use it okay look this top these
top lines right here are about
income if you hate sales
you hate income skill number three learn
from mistakes with kevin o'leary there
is no lesson in life
like failure the idea that you're going
to be successful in all your endeavors
is complete bs
that never happens for anybody the most
important lessons you can
learn are from failure why that's
the definition of experience failing
getting up getting back at it getting
back in the race
is what experience is and the key to
that is
every time you fail because there'll be
more than once you have to learn from it
you do not want to do that again that's
the whole idea
the more you fail the better you become
because you don't make those mistakes
over again
but i wish for everybody in a good way
now that you understand it a
catastrophic failure something that
makes you
cry that you just want to sit in a dark
closet for saying
why did i do that how did that happen
and then you learn
from it that's absolutely crucial
you know i actually remember sitting in
a dark room thinking about a mistake i
made i think
i i think i was like 15 years old but it
you know these these moments in your
life
really stick and they help you grow i
have failed a lot
many failures i can give you some i just
gave you one earlier
i lost hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of dollars at least on paper
for a long time shorting yahoo that was
a big mistake stupid of me to do that
then i started a business you know i
started many startups when i was an
operator that actually failed one was
one was involved with one of the giant
cable companies
and i probably spent about 18 months on
that
made no money lost a lot i think in that
case about
750 000 ouch that hurts it really stung
i've invested in other deals some were
friends some were other business
associates that went to zero
generally in a startup i'll put up about
250
000 and wait and see what happens then
put more in and there was one that i
that i put 250 into and then within six
months they needed more money
even though my gut was telling me don't
invest in it
i put another 250 and within six months
lost another half million
i've made many mistakes but i learn from
my mistakes
that's the key i am not going to be
successful
in everything i do and i want you to
embrace that idea as an entrepreneur you
are not
going to be successful all the time
you will make many many mistakes
and it's okay it's okay as long as you
learn
from it now i don't make the same
mistakes anymore i make
new mistakes i learn from those again
and that's what's called experience the
difference between when you start your
career when you get to the middle of it
in the end
is all the mistakes you've made and what
you've learned from them and the older
you get
the more you've learned and that's the
whole idea and when i work with young
entrepreneurs today and with my teams
and my companies
i try and explain to them the mistakes
i've made so they don't make the same
ones
that's the whole idea but it i've made
millions of dollars of mistakes and and
i
you know i once i once ran as a
politician and lost millions of dollars
doing that
was that was that a mistake was a
learning experience i'm still
haven't decided yet but it's sort of
it's sort of those experiences in life
are are made up the patina of life the
rest of life
the coding of life is is all the
experiences not just the successes
but the failures you've made when i look
at great entrepreneurs today maybe you
even and johnny
what will make you successful is
experience that you'll take
and have those tools in your memory to
use when you have to make your pivot
great entrepreneurs do that all the time
don't let a crisis ever be wasted you
learn something from it
and then you move forward because you
might not use it that day
but you're going to use it one day and
it's going to be tremendously valuable
for you
i would personally rather invest someone
who has felt the
sting of failure and is motivated by the
fear of failing a fourth time
than someone who thinks they can never
fail because it will
visit everybody it just does i've had
plenty of failures
sometimes it's luck mike sometimes it's
just
being in the wrong place at the wrong
time three times in a row
and the fourth is the one that's going
to work i'd invest in that guy
sure i think he probably has learned
something from his
mistakes and that's sometimes what they
are but failure
i mean it is just part of everybody's
life
and there's many ways to fail and it's
really easy to fail and very hard to
succeed
let's talk about writing books because
i'm working on my fourth now
i'm hating every minute of it but i
think it's going to be my best but
i always say that every book how do you
do yours
this book came when i was on tour last
year and
i was hitting the city every four days
and doing a speech in front of a group
and
the questions that people ask me i just
kept
kept like a note of what people kept
asking me over and over again and then
it turned it into
and you you got thematically you would
get some very
questions over and over again that
people had right you say that is a
kernel that's an important question
because they keep getting it all the
time is that the idea
yeah i was on tour and people kept
asking me how do i find my purpose how
do i find my purpose how do i find my
prayers like
the number one question in every city
across america
i said well that's pretty easy you don't
have to
sit on top of a mountain for 10 years or
hire a 20 000
business coach you know there's a three
step process to find your purpose
and i just guided them through it and
then everyone's hey pick me pick me do
it with me it's like okay well
i'll turn it into a book and that became
built to serve sounds good
i gotta read that book man that sounds
pretty good i gotta find my purpose
i've really enjoyed our time today it's
great you're a good guy
i'm gonna endorse you
that's fantastic skill number four learn
how to raise money with robert kiyosaki
i took you know three companies public
through toronto i mean
through first with vc vancouver stock
exchange and i thought i might migrate
to the toronto stock exchange why did i
do that
to learn learn to help how to raise
capital on public markets
now the average entrepreneur never does
that you know they keep open their pizza
shop and they open two pizza shops
and that's that's about it because
they're into just for that money
i wanted to learn something so i i took
my first um
first was an oil company in portugal and
i took that public and everybody told me
there's no oil in portugal
and i found out the hard way they're
right there's no oil there
that company crashed and burned like a
airplane coming out of the sky you know
and then the next thing i started a
silver company in argentina and we
struck silver and we did very well
yeah and then i started a gold company
in china
and the chinese took it so uh
those are priceless experience you know
yeah aren't you bitter i go
yeah but that's what i did it for you
understand that
i did it for that i made the my usual
wise ass remark
only lazy people use their own money and
that's because
i have spent much of my life raising
capital you know today you have crowd
funding and all that stuff
but the reason i had to learn to raise
money was because i had no money
and so if you read rich dad poor dad
in there my rich dad always said never
say
i can't afford it and it was my rich dad
and many of my teachers
subsequent to that they said
lazy people always say i can't afford it
i don't have the money that's why
they're poor
they have a poor mindset so instead of
figuring out
how to raise money it's just really easy
to be a loser and i call
losers it pisses them off
because we all have the power if we
wanted to
to not be poor if we learned how to
raise money
skill number five learn business
principles with warren buffett
everything you do learn is cumulative i
mean that doesn't mean that
industries stay good forever or
businesses take good forever but
but learning to think about business
models what i learned at 20 is useful to
me now what i learned at 25 is useful to
me now and so
it's not it's not so it's not a field
that
changes dramatically in terms of the
underlying principles it's like physics
i mean there's underlying principles now
they're doing all kinds of things with
physics they weren't doing 50 years ago
but
but if you know the if you've got the
principles if you know what makes a good
business if you know what makes a good
manager
you know if you know what makes a a good
product uh
and you learn that in one business you
can there is some transference
to other businesses as you go along and
you learn what things you you're not
going to understand i mean
knowing what to leave out is just as
important as knowing what to focus on
and uh i don't think i can win every
game you know
somebody said how do you beat bobby
fischer you play him any game except
chess
so i don't play bobby fischer chess
and that's there's a lot of value to
learning that over time and
and learning what you're good at and
what you're not good at skill number six
is innovate with elon musk what sort of
things do you look for in people
or in processes that make the workforce
better sure
well i think the massive thing that can
be done
is to make sure your incentive structure
is such that
uh innovation is rewarded and lack of
innovation is punished
there's got to be a characteristic so
if somebody is innovating
and doing making good progress
then they should be promoted sooner
and if somebody is completely failing to
innovate um
not every role requires innovation but
uh if they're
in a role where innovation is
should be happening and it's not
happening then they should
either not be promoted or exited and let
me tell you you'll get promote you'll
get
you'll you'll get innovation real fast
the real way i think you you actually
achieve
intellectual property protection is by
innovating
fast enough if your rate of innovation
is high
then you don't need to worry about
protecting vip
because other companies will be copying
something that you did years ago
[Music]
and that's fine you know
just make sure your rate of innovation
is fast
um speed is really speed of innovation
is what is what matters
um and i do i do say this to my teams
like
quite a lot that innovation per unit
time as i go
innovation per year if you want to say
like is is what matters not
innovation absent time because
if you wanted to make say um 100
improvement in something
and that took 100 years or one year
that's radically different
so it's like what is your rate of
innovation
that that matters and is the rate of
innovation
is that accelerating or decelerating
um and a weird thing happens when
companies get big is that
most companies um or organizations the
bigger they get
they tend to get less innovative
um not just less innovative on a per
person basis but less innovative in the
absolute
and i think this is probably because the
incentive structure is not
is not there for innovation
it it's not enough to use words to
encourage innovation
the incentive structure must be aligned
with that
that's fundamental first of all when we
interview people we we do ask
for some evidence of exceptional ability
which
in most cases includes innovation
uh this is not said everyone needs to be
innovative it's
but we certainly need those that are
doing advanced engineering
to be innovative um and ideally everyone
is
at least some to some degree innovative
uh so
at the interview point we
select for it for people who who want to
create new technology and then the
incentive structure
is set up that such that
innovation is rewarded um making
mistakes
along the way does not come with a big
penalty
um and but but but failure to
try to innovate at all comes with a big
penalty
you'll be fired okay yeah
all right the carrot and stick that's
the stick if you don't even try
or or somebody doesn't even try to
invade or
their innovation aspirations are are
very are
not not very good then
yeah they will no longer be at the
company and skill number seven the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is develop communication skills with dan
lok
billionaires understand people from my
observation billionaires they have
exceptional people skills now some of
them are great communicators
they are great public speakers some of
them are world-class
negotiators or closers they could get
deal done they could close deals
they know how to negotiate with the
banks
now having good people skills doesn't
mean that they want to be liked
all the time in fact most of them
they're not that nice
they are tough they're tough because
they have been screwed over
they have been taken advantage of
they've been sued right they've been
backstabbed
they have a lot of scar tissues right
they have a lot of
heat right a lot of people wanting
something from them so
they have thick skin and almost without
exception
they all have world-class leadership
skills
they know how to lead people they
understand people
they know how to motivate people they
know how to put a team together
they understand that it takes people to
get stuff done
you need to know how to get people
together work together as a team
and not working against each other and
that is tough
i also notice they are willing to invest
time in developing
key relationships and most of them are
very generous and they are
willing to help people one of the things
that almost all
millionaires have in common is they have
exceptional i mean exceptional
communication skills because they
recognize that
communication equals wealth now it could
be communication skill in terms of
public speaking one-to-many or
communication skills like
this one-on-one sales closing
negotiation it could be communication in
terms of
in print i call that copywriting they
have exceptional
communication skills they know how to
get the ideas across
they know how to persuade influence and
convince someone to take action
because that's the only way you can
create leverage in life and that's
the very first step to create wealth
when i immigrated to north america
i didn't know anybody i had no context i
couldn't speak the language
so if that's the case one of the things
i want to teach you is to
rephrase and refrain from thinking of oh
i don't have any context
context is not something that you have
context is something you go and get you
got to go
get them right if you don't have it no
good it's just well i don't have any
contacts
you got to go get it if you move to a
new city
you don't know anybody go to local
chamber of commerce right there a lot of
business people there
go there meet with people mingle with
people that's very good now
usually the qualities by the way are not
super good that's okay
you start somewhere you're not gonna
have the context
that like what i have today overnight
told me how many years
start somewhere what else bought a trade
go there a lot of business people go to
events
whenever the events business events
personal development events
go there anyone that you know you'll
meet people who are growth oriented
people who are ambitious go there buy a
ticket spend a few dollars don't be a
cheap ass
right go there meet with people and now
once you become a little bit better
maybe you can join local toastmasters
and toastmasters
is a non-profit organization that
teaches the skill of public speaking
if you join a tourist master club in a
business area chances are
there are the business people go there
and meet with those people
most people they are afraid to present
they're afraid to speak to
groups and that's what makes public
speaking so valuable
companies and organizations they're
always looking for
speakers and they're willing to pay a
good
premium for good speakers so public
speaking skill
not easy to develop because most people
are afraid
they're afraid of rejection they're
afraid of public embarrassment but if
you could overcome that
and you have an expertise that is
valuable to corporation and company
public speaking skill it is a great
skill to master
back then when i was going to high
school in
canada and vancouver i had no friends
right because i was very much an
introvert i was very shy
because i couldn't speak a language when
i first arrived
to this country i couldn't speak a word
of english so
i was very afraid to talk to people of
course when you're afraid to talk to
people
no one would listen and i remember i
would try to
communicate very very even simple
language simple words
with my classmates and they were like
what
what they say part of me and i would
have to repeat the same
thing three four five times and because
they just won't listen and
eventually they pretty much just lose
their patience they're like i don't i
can't understand you man
i can't understand what you're talking
about so they don't want to talk to me
because they feel it's
it's it's very troublesome for them
right
so i know for a fact when you see what i
do when i'm now communicating with you
that i can speak i can commend an
audience and our friends
you know from all over the world that
communication
this is a learnable skill
it is a what it's a learnable skill
this is something that you could learn i
could go from someone who's a totally
introvert
shy no one would listen to me to now
that people would listen to what i have
to say now i've got some special bonus
clips that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
when you just watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action
but when you watch a video you get
motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you you will never
lose in life if you have valuable skills
you won't lose your house you won't lose
your car you won't lose your clients if
you have a skill that brings people
value
the economy can collapse the algorithms
can change
but as long as you have a skill that
solves problems for people
you will be safe so i'm seeing this a
lot in the youtube world now
i have a new course out helping people
get to a million subscribers on youtube
we can link up the description there
if you want in and people are saying
well should i still do youtube is it too
late like
youtube won't be here in five years or
10 years or maybe it's gonna be the next
thing that should hop on
it's not about the platform like right
now it's winning the platform that is
currently winning
you need to crush it right like youtube
should be your home if you're trying to
make an impact you're trying to be a
thought leader you have a message to
spread
youtube has to be your number one place
it just has to be right now otherwise
you're
not making a smart decision but whether
youtube is still around in 20 years
five years doesn't matter because the
skill set that you
learn you can take anywhere the ability
to communicate
you could take to any platform you could
take to the next thing i don't
anticipate youtube still being around in
20 years but my ability to make videos
talking to a lens that's not gonna go
away that can serve me for life right
whether that's
vr evan or hologram evan you know coming
into your living room that's
that's gonna be me that's gonna be
amazing i'm pumped i look forward to it
any algorithm change that people are
freaking out about anybody who's
complaining about
the economy going down or the algorithm
changing you've already lost that's a
losing mindset
when i was first starting my youtube
channel i always saw the algorithm as a
chance to win
right you should see if you're a small
creator on any platform
youtube instagram anything and the
algorithm shifts
that's your greatest advantage you
should be cheering you should want more
algorithm changes
if you look at a traditional established
boring market uh it's hard to win real
estate could be hard to win
right financial markets can be hard to
win it's not that it's not possible it's
just hard to win because there's a lot
of people who have
who have decades of experience and no
more than you and it's hard to close
that gap of experience
with social media with youtube every
time there's a big algorithm change the
people who are
experts at the last thing they're crying
instead of adjusting that's how you win
that's how you get ahead of them that's
how you become the top dog
is because you're gonna go learn the new
algorithm when everybody is wishing and
hoping that the old algorithm comes back
and this happens for every platform it
happened for facebook every time they
changed your algorithm or updated the
the feed and what was shown there
people always freak out and complain and
they signed they want petitions and like
let's go back to what it used to be
don't sign those petitions don't jump on
that penguin that is loser thinking
never
ever ever ever ever ever ever do that
it's loser thinking and that's how most
people think
that's a mindset shift that i want to
make for the collective but more
importantly for you
that whenever there's a big change
embrace it go all in on it learn it
that's how you're going to leapfrog
everybody else
so the faster the rate of change the
more you should be cheering i still get
pumped for an algorithm change
me i mean now i'm at now i'm closer to
the top right i mean i don't know what
the top is i got 2 million subscribers
and 300 million views and all these
channels
i still love it anytime an algorithm
change comes out i'm still pumped train
yourself like a change is coming i'm
pumped
get excited because there's still people
who are ahead of me or even the people
below me that i'm competing with
for for attention and for space if
they're sitting there complaining about
how it's changed
and they're dropping in their views
awesome i'll pick up those views because
i'm going to learn what the new
algorithm is all about
same thing with the economy when the
economy crashes everybody who's
complaining about how it used to be
they're not gonna win it's comforting to
join a club and wish things would be how
they used to be but we're not going back
to that
so the faster you realize that and make
improvements the faster you can learn
and actually build a great business
some of the greatest businesses in the
world are built in recession in
depression
that could be you if you decide to be
let's hop back to skills for a second i
look at
jake paul logan paul they started on
vine right vine was
was their claim to fame they had tons of
success in making these super short
videos
vine gets shut down right boom gone this
is don't put all your eggs in one basket
i think that's loser thinking too it's
loser thinking
they went all in on vine and and then
vine got shut down oh no
what did they do they moved to youtube
instead of crushing it millions of
subscribers look at their growth on
youtube
over the past i don't know two years
three years blew up
why they didn't just come out of nowhere
they had the skill set
they had the skill set that they learned
from doing the thing
right the skill set to make a good video
they then brought to a new platform if
youtube goes away
you're learning the skill set of how to
communicate how to make great videos
that
whatever comes next people are freaking
out about
the ftc coming in and cop on youtube
okay so if kids aren't
able to get content on youtube where
they're gonna go go be there
instead of trying to fight what is
already happening
go be at the place where the kids are
gonna be
embrace the change that's where you
that's where you can win when everybody
else is fighting and angry and screaming
and yelling and complaining and wishing
it used to be or quitting the platform
and
getting upset go be where they're gonna
be it's it's easy it's a simple win
most people don't have that mindset it's
why most people lose my most businesses
can't evolve most businesses shut down
it's people
very rarely transition from one platform
to another from one business to another
even though they have the skill sets and
capabilities to do so because they don't
have the mindset to do so
people who crushed myspace very few of
them are still around
on different platforms looking at look
at hollywood the rock is doing it
will smith is doing it moving from
hollywood films to youtube
where's brad pitt where's george clooney
like they're in a dying industry
they should be embracing youtube they
don't want it they have the skills they
have the skills it's transferable
you don't think george clinton could
come in and crush youtube if you wanted
to
of course he could calling you out
george clooney let's go make it happen
right so it's about picking up the skill
set that will keep you safe in any
environment
but it's also having a mindset to follow
through and try the new things instead
of complaining about the changes that
are currently happening
so how can you do it i'm going to give
you a three-step process that i think
will help
step one is make sure your actions map
to your missions this will help you
determine what skill set you need
what are your ambitions what do you want
to accomplish what do you want in our
life there's so many ways to win
you know if you've gone through the who
why how process you know what your
purpose is you know what you're trying
to accomplish you've
you've read built a survey you can't
read it yet still in pre-order but
you understand the concept you figure
out your purpose great to actually go
off and accomplish it
what are the skill sets that you
actually need what are the skills that
you need to develop even if you suck at
it if you're not naturally good at it
i'm
introverted i'm not naturally good in
front of the camera took me 6 000 videos
to get here
right i got better with practice and
repetition and dedication hard work and
all of that
you can too what are the skill sets that
you need to acquire
to get the life that you want and then
you can start working on them so first
step
is figure out how do you map your
actions to your ambitions
second step is to learn to tell yourself
that it's the best it's the best
it's the best every time something
negative is happening to you
the economy is crashing and algorithm is
changing a new competitor comes in
something something negative is
happening
you tell yourself it's the best this is
the best
is my chance to prove to myself and the
world what i'm made of
when an algorithm changes and you say
it's the best
you're gonna find a new solution if you
sit there and complain and get negative
and toxic you're not gonna find a new
solution
the best part of saying it's the best is
it shifts your mindset
from one of complaining and lack of
resourcefulness to one of
ultimate resources to be able to say i'm
gonna go solve this thing
let's go it shifts your mindset so many
people get stuck
in the negativity even if you're an
entrepreneur and you're positive and
optimistic and
have great hopes for the future where
you want to go if you spend all this
time and energy building up this thing
and it gets taken away from you it's
really hard to say this is the best
but that's what you need to do because
otherwise you spend the rest of your
life
living off of past glory to say well
this is what i used to be and it was all
taken away from me and now my life sucks
like you want the next 40 years of your
life to be
thinking like that no it's the best
the economy crashes it's the best you're
gonna crush it
algorithm changes it's the best you're
gonna crush it new competitor comes in
it's the best
you're gonna crush it right
you grow through difficult times you get
better through a difficult time you
don't wanna do the same thing over and
over and over and over again that's
boring that's photocopying your life
that's not what you want
you wanna grow you want to progress
self-confidence self-love
all of it comes from doing difficult
things by telling yourself that when
that difficult thing comes
it's the best this is my chance to rise
up
and show myself and the world what i'm
capable of
as opposed to saying this sucks and
sitting in negativity all day
all week all month all year all decade
and step number three is understand that
the quantity leads to the quality we
figured out what our skill is that we
want to get good at right
we understand that it's the best that
when other people are complaining we're
going to rise up and improve our skills
and get better at the thing because
that's how we're going to win
and now number three is the practice the
daily grind the
constant improvement i've done 6 000
videos that's how i got better at this
the thing that you want to get great at
you have to do a lot of you're going to
suck at the beginning
you're not going to have any quality
that's okay that's great it's the best
right but then through repetition
through practice through daily hustle
attacking the thing the thing that you
love doing even though other people see
it as work and torture
you love it you're getting better at it
that's how you're going to improve your
skills
every skill set is possible to acquire
it's just a skill doesn't mean you suck
as a human just means you don't have the
skill set yet
how do you get the skill set by
practicing the quantity leads to the
quality and so back to point number one
of your actions map to your ambitions
how much are you practicing you want to
acquire the skill set how much time are
you actually spending
on that skill set you want to be a great
editor great how much time are you
spending editing want to be a great
piano player how much time you're
spending piano
right you might have some natural
ability for it awesome
and if you don't i had no natural
ability to be good in front of the
camera
go back and watch my first videos you'll
see you'll see how much i sucked
no natural ability zero this took a long
time
practice dedication hard work
right action snap to your ambitions by
putting the quantity that leads to the
quality
how much are you doing show me your
calendar show yourself your calendar
pull up your calendar look at your next
week look at your next month
that skill that you want to acquire it's
going to save you from the recession
from the algorithm change that's going
to bring people value that skill that
you need to acquire it's going to pay
you
how much time you spend in developing it
and if it's not a lot if it's not
sometime every day you got to change
your mindset you got to change your
calendar you need to change your actions
because right now if that's you your
actions are not mapping to your missions
i want you to win you need to get the
skill sets that's the path the fastest
path for you to get to success you're
after is to model success
the idea here is simple you find people
who have already done the thing that you
want to do
learn from them understand what they did
to get there and then try
on their hat right see what worked for
them and apply it to your business
this is what worked for me this is what
saved my company bill gates
saved my first company even though i've
never met him i haven't yet
we're going to make it happen hopefully
hopefully hopefully soon
i was struggling i had a upstart
software company that wasn't making
money
and i quit on my business partner and i
woke up the next day and said i need to
find a way to make this happen
like i can't quit on this too soon
because i'm going to regret it if i
don't keep going
and so i said who has done this before
who's done this
and i thought of bill gates which is the
first person that came to mind was bill
gates so i looked at his story and how
did he
build microsoft was through partnerships
and so
i started making partnerships in my
business i had nothing else to lose i
was already at rock bottom right here
quit on my partner
it was hopeless so let's just give this
a shot
and within i don't know a couple months
maybe even sooner
i landed my first partnership deal for
13 and a half thousand dollars and at
the time guys i was making 300 bucks a
month so that money
meant the world to me like that was that
was bank and and more important than
that it it gave me hope you know like
this could happen this this business
could actually work
and it gave me a model to then go and do
it again and again and again and ever
since then
whenever i don't know what to do i model
success i find someone who's done it
and i try to apply their strategies and
make it work for me
but this is the important thing not
every strategy is going to work the same
way
for them as it did for you so maybe
waking up early is your ticket maybe
waking up later
is going to be your ticket there's
people who've done both which is the one
that's going to work for you
you won't know by sitting on the couch
and thinking about it the best thing you
can do
is just go and try you try on their hat
right bill gates did this dan lok does
this bruce lee does this
awesome try it try it and see people
pre-judge
so early you have to change your habits
if you want to get something more than
you have right now it's because you're
doing something different than what
you're doing right now
and different is scary different means
you don't know what's going to work out
or not different
is different we don't want to do
different right you want to stay inside
our comfort zone that's not where your
success is going to come
but not everything you try is going to
work even the ones that do work won't
work 100 percent
the way that bill gates did partnerships
and his business is different than the
way that i did it
but just that idea alone took me 80
percent of the way modeling success
takes you 80 percent of the way and then
that final
20 is you got to make the adjustments to
make it your own
because otherwise you just end up being
a junior version of somebody else
instead of being you
but i think we're too often just judging
people you're judging a strategy saying
well that's not going to work for me
without even trying it
and so i have this channel where you can
learn from people every day i have my
top 10 rules where you can watch those
videos and learn from people every day
if you watch a top 10 video these are 10
rules for some of the most successful
people on the planet in the history of
humanity here they are with 10 different
lessons
not all of those 10 lessons have to work
for you have to apply to you
take one of them take two of them and
just do something just apply it to your
life apply it to your business and see
if you get a result
that's the key and so you need to get
out of your head you need to get out of
your own way and you need to just start
doing
the best thing you can do is go from
idea to action when you see something
that kind of makes sense that might be a
fit for you
just start doing it stop judging
start doing it and apply it to your
business and see if it works
give it a shot
[Music]
if you want to learn the five universal
skills that will make you rich check out
the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there rule number one
and whenever you forget this rule you're
already out of business
you don't need to have this humongous
gpa and all this other
what you need is the one thing i talked
about my book